دخلت البلاد في صمتها الانتخابي لكن ثمه
ما يسمع في جنوب البلاد تحديدا في ولايه
كهرمان مرعش والولايات الاخرى التي تعرضت
لزلزال كارثي قبل اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر في
مرعش هناك اكثر من 750 الف ناخب لهم
التصميم ايضا في الولايات العشر الاخرى
هناك اكثر من ثمانيه ملايين ونصف المليون
ناخب يحق لهم التصوير هؤلاء كانوا محطه
انظار واهتمام المرشحين طيله الاشهر
الماضيه اثار الزلزال ما زالت باديه حتى
هذه اللحظه هناك بيوت جاهزه تم يعني
تثبيتها في مناطق الزلزال وما زالت عمليات
ازاله المباني الاله للسقوط مستمره وايضا
ما زالت عمليات ازاله بعض الانقاذ
المتبقيه من هذه المناطق مستمره حتى هذه
اللحظه هذه المناطق ربما تكون بيضه القبان
للفائز في الانتخابات